wednesday edition
p-f-t-o-t the extra little show that we
do after pft live when we just literally
wrapped up pft live minutes ago some
topics we didn't get to and some things
we'd like to expand upon and chris one
thing that i think isn't surprising to
anyone but it's still very confusing cam
newton this foot injury that was
aggravated last week between the
shoulder between the foot between the
ankle between this between that the guy
who looks indestructible isn't
indestructible and now that he's 30 and
we saw andrew luck retire and i just
have to wonder
whether or not cam newton can continue
to keep going physically and how long he
will tolerate these kinds of injuries
and annoyances and surgeries and rehabs
if it means he's going to go out there
and he's not going to be the guy he used
to be i just feel like it's starting to
add up to possibly cam newton joining
andrew luck and no longer playing
football maybe as soon as this year
maybe next year if not then the year
after
man
i i mean i i
listen am i concerned a little bit about
cam newton
yes i understand that i mean yeah we
know i mean he's been the most physical
quarterback we've ever seen in the
history of football i mean just go look
at his numbers and all the attempts he's
had on you know third and shorts and
fourth and shorts through his career i
mean other quarterbacks who we look at
and they go oh they quarterback sneak a
lot cam newton's like double those
people and they're not quarterback
sneaks they're literally like car
crashes the middle linebackers where he
gets a running start uh from the shotgun
position so yeah his body's been beat to
crap there's no doubt about it and uh
where it is a little concerning i'll say
this i don't think i don't know he
doesn't strike me as a guy that would
walk away i think he loves football i
feel like he does um i don't know maybe
he does have other interests maybe i'm
reading this wrong but i think the other
thing that's at least worth bringing up
here though mike that jumps out to me
you do have to
i think as the carolina panthers start
to question how you structure your next
contract with cam newton or where you go
there because i would be concerned that
yeah he's gonna fall apart or how much
longer of a beating can he take
and i look at it from the standpoint of
that accumulation of injuries plus that
that demeanor that we see from him when
things aren't going his way and it's
fine it's not a criticism but it's a
reality when the day is going well it's
the big smile it's the superman thing
it's it's a very different vibe than
when the game isn't going his way and
i've always been critical from the
standpoint of you need to be more even
keel than that because you need to hold
out hope that you can turn a day that
isn't your day into your day that you
can turn around a bad game with the
right mindset but if he is on that
emotional roller coaster and you do
spend enough time on the downward slope
and you know that you've got more than
enough money that you don't need to do
this anymore maybe you just decide i'm
not going to do it anymore and when you
look at his contract he's got two more
years in carolina
maybe he realizes after this contract
expires the money's just not going to be
there for a cam newton because he can't
be counted upon to be healthy and
effective on a regular basis that is the
one factor that gets overlooked when it
comes to quarterbacks franchise
quarterbacks you got to be available to
your franchise dak prescott 50 games 50
starts that's what you've got to do to
be a long term year in and year out
valuable franchise quarterback because
if you're not healthy and you can't play
you're worthless to your team yeah no
that's those are all real things you're
right and yeah at the age of 30 and you
know la you know last year with the
shoulder injury not looking the way he's
looking right now and it does you know
not that he's missed a lot of time uh
but it does seem like he's been battling
a lot the last few years with just
little you know nagging injuries here
and there but i would be shocked if it
was like an andrew luck style of walking
away i don't think he's that type of guy
i think he's going to continue to push
forward
i just think at a certain point you have
to make a decision for yourself for your
family for your future and if it isn't
fun anymore if the joy is gone at what
point do you say i don't need this in my
life i do have other interests these
guys aren't required to play until they
rip the uniform off of them right and uh
you know for the same reasons andrew
luck walked away maybe cam newton will
decide
i've had enough and maybe when he sees
what kind of numbers are put on the
table as the market gets closer and
closer to 40 million
if nobody values him as a 30 million a
year guy he may say
i'm out i'm not doing this but but i
think it's something to pay attention to
because that performance last thursday
night was very uncam newton-like yeah
and it's because of his foot and if he
can't get his foot healed if he can't
get his shoulder right at some point i
think you just say
that's it i've made my money i'm going
to move on now the panthers will need
someone to step in and play quarterback
if cam newton is out for any period of
time kyle allen will be the starter will
greer will be the backup coach ron
rivera said that on tuesday but
meanwhile
people are ignoring colin kaepernick and
i remember saying two years ago chris
when cam newton was rehabbing from a
surgery i think it was an ankle surgery
at the time boy colin kaepernick would
be the perfect quarterback for the
offseason program while cam newton
recovers it's it's similar skill set and
and kaepernick can come in and prove
that he's not radioactive that teammates
will respond to him kind of a pallet
cleanser after everything that happened
in san francisco and they had maybe a
mutual deal that wants cam newton's
healthy they cut colin kaepernick and he
goes and finds another job i mean i i
remember thinking then this would be a
perfect replacement for cam newton just
as it relates to the off season program
yeah now isn't he a perfect replacement
for cam newton if cam newton can't play
i mean yes the can you know the colin
kaepernick that we saw a few years ago
would be the perfect replacement but you
know and again i don't like this i mean
it's messed up i get it i mean colin
kaepernick would fit perfectly within
that cam newton carolina panthers system
but that was the colin kaepernick it's
just been too long mike i mean i would
have a hard time just as a football
you know coach personnel guy to go
oh okay yeah we're going to sign colin
kaepernick who hasn't been in any live
action and we're going to bring him in
here and you know realistically think
that he can get up to speed and play at
a high level pretty quickly let alone
it's still a lightning rod subject and i
just again i i it's messed up but i just
don't think there's any way
we ever see colin kaepernick and i've
been saying that since the first time he
knelt that he would never play again
when that season was over and and i
still
feel strongly about that
instead of waiting for the phone to ring
his agent has begun reaching out to the
teams that have quarterback needs i
don't know that it's going to make any
bit of a difference and the thing that
bugs me the most is the fact that by
successfully blackballing him for two
years yeah the fact that he hasn't
played in two years now becomes the
first argument right in why you
shouldn't sign it i know and it was you
know they managed to weather the storm
so now they can use the fact that that
they've screwed them over to continue to
screw them over you're right
and
what but here's the thing don't you want
to win football games i mean david
tepper signed eric reed last year don't
you want to win and don't you want to
sell merchandise can you imagine how
much money they would make off of colin
kaepernick panthers jerseys are you sure
about that i don't know oh i think i
think they would sell i think they would
sell plenty of them i don't know there's
no guarantee you're gonna win for one
and then but yet i don't it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter if you win if
you create a colin kaepernick jersey
for any nfl team right now it will sell
i'm telling he was one of the top
selling jerseys
like a year after he wasn't playing for
the 49ers
wide but like
if if somebody like the carolina
panthers did it i i still think there's
in that part of the country there's
going to be tremendous backlash
tremendous they won't they're going to
think yeah is it i don't i think you're
i think you're wrong i i think you are
listening to a vocal segment of the fan
base that has the same bit of purchasing
power as the silent portion of the fan
base that has no problem with colin
kaepernick being on the team and this
happens too much in our society nowadays
a vocal minority hijacks the process and
the nfl has allowed that to happen i
remember when the collusion case was
still boiling as it relates to colin
kaepernick in the nfl some of the
evidence that was going to be introduced
related to surveys the nfl did where
they they saw that you know there was
just as many people in favor of
kaepernick having a job as there were
against but the ones who were against
were so loud right that they listened to
them instead of the ones who had no
problem with it and it's just it's it's
just the whole thing is sad to me and
there's the knee-jerk reaction that if
you if you add the guy was in a super
bowl jim harbaugh told me within the
last couple of years this is a guy who
can win championships in the nfl not one
plural and definitely i know whether
it's the look i know the steelers are
all in with mason rudolph but why don't
you bring in colin kaepernick to be
mason rudolph's backup and maybe at some
point colin kaepernick is good enough
that he's better than mason rudolph
you're trying to win football games the
panthers are trying to win football
games presumably these people want to
win and they're overlooking a guy who
could help them win all because they're
trying to win a completely different
battle than who scores more points on a
football field yeah no i i mean you're
mike i mean i i am
i am not fighting against you i hope you
don't think i am i'm totally in
agreement with all your thoughts i'm
just trying to
like be realistic look at nike right
nike yeah remember when nike did a deal
with him last year labor day weekend
right and all the kaepernick haters said
it's going to destroy nike and what did
it do the stock kept going up and up and
up and up sure there is a segment of
society out yes but they don't reside in
carolina they don't reside there that
that part of society does not reside
there new york
san francisco some of those cities yes
but i think if you got into the south
right now okay and not trying to get
political and you just get into certain
cities i'm not i'm not even trying to i
just think they're right you're not
trying to you just are well i'm just
saying the writing is on the wall in
some of the cities to where i don't
think you're gonna get away with it
that's all i'm saying i just i look at
it very and here here's the problem the
people who don't like him for
non-football reasons cling to the
weakest football arguments to justify
him not playing and they are weak and
they are flawed and they've always been
flawed and now the strongest argument is
well he hasn't played in two years yeah
because he was successfully blackballed
by the nfl and its teams for two years
yes all right so messed up yeah it is so
freaking messed up it's unreal i know
that yes
let's move on to the new york jets now
they're a team that needs a quarterback
but sam darnold is going to be back from
mono fairly soon they like lick luke
falk they've added david fails they like
luke falk they're sticking with luke
faulk he completed 20 of 25 passes on
monday night in that game against the
browns they just couldn't sustain their
offense so i think faulk is the guy
until darnold comes back and they're not
going to go out and try to find a
veteran whether it be colin kaepernick
or anyone else darnold to be back they
hope by week five but you know they got
some hope in luke faulk although vegas
doesn't share the optimism they're still
22 23 and a half point underdogs yeah
well uh
i get i get them staying with luke falk
i mean he's had a ton of reps through
his college career throwing the ball at
washington state i mean you know they
don't even know what a run play is there
so he's certainly you know uh polished
as far as getting those type of reps uh
and and he did look good you're right
you know i i don't know if there's any
backup quarterback you sit out there
right now and just go oh gosh he's going
to be so much better than luke falk i
get that adam gase you heard on one of
the uh comments during monday night
football they felt like he knew the
offense better than anybody better than
trevor simeon and sam darnold so that's
going to make them feel comfortable the
big thing is is like he's not super
gifted so it's just going to be hard
okay because they don't have the right
team around him to completely support
him right now you know you might be able
to get away with this at luke falk and
if you had a really awesome running game
and a good all offensive line and a top
tier defense in football but the jets
don't have that and you know i think he
can manage the offense and do some good
things but right now for them to win
games or do that they need somebody that
can like make some big time plays and
that's not going to happen and with
their schedule
i mean
night night
that's all i can say that they're going
0 and 6. they're going 0-6 they're just
unless sam darnold becomes back in these
next four games 0-6 jets is going to be
a real thing four weeks from now
it's just sad that it's happened that
way and really when you look at that 16
nothing lead that they held right it's
the buffalo bills if they could have
just finagled that win and then you
throw the mono on top of it i mean i
it's just amazing and every year there's
a team where these
these adversities one after another just
keep popping up and it's been associated
with adam gates the last three years two
in miami and now with the new york jets
the pittsburgh steelers have had plenty
of adversity with the injury that ended
the season of quarterback ben
roethlisberger now receiver dante
montreal got so much hype and so much
buzz before the season chris as the
viable number two yeah to juju smith
schuster he's on the verge of getting
benched he's hardly done anything this
year he's got a lot of drops he can't
get open he's got three catches for
seven yards and five drops they signed
him to a two-year nine million dollar
contract they thought it was a steal and
now it looks like he's gonna head to the
benz james washington who was a teammate
of mason rudolph's at oklahoma state
could bump up deontay johnson the rookie
could bump up but uh you know and if
moncrie falls far enough on the depth
chart they may think about getting rid
of him because at some point you got to
be playing special teams and moncrief
may not want to do that and the steelers
may have an issue that if they don't
believe in him as one of their top
receivers he may just be gone yeah i get
them benching them that's for sure i
mean i really do i mean you know week
one there was there was two or three
plays that were there to be had and
dante moncrief didn't come through and
he was part of the reason they got blown
out of the gym there in in foxborough i
mean he catches that what was it a
fourth and one right if he catches that
i think he had another ball in the end
zone that he catches i mean that game
could at least got competitive for a
little while uh but it has not looked
good and the whole
receiver options for the pittsburgh
steelers is just not that good it's not
that special james washington's good
player but he's nowhere near like a
number one or even a good number two you
know uh dante moncrief obviously proving
he's not you know can deontay johnson
the rookie they drafted in the third or
fourth round out of toledo he's a guy i
look forward that has a little hope
because he can make some things happen
uh but he's young and i'm learning on
the fly too i mean this is just this is
kind of the the crazy thing i think we
all took for granted a little bit
the steelers have been so great of
evaluating receivers and i think i fell
into this trap with evaluating the
steelers too that they've been so great
at the receiver position that you know
that they i was trusting that they saw
more in their receivers like we'll be
okay these guys are going to make this
next step we'll they're going to be fine
and i trusted in that and uh of course
we're wrong and then uh i don't trust
that and they don't have guys that can
get open other than juju
and and even juju now that he's facing
all that extra attention he's got to try
to force his way down the field and
develop a deep route in his passing game
it's it's just not going the way that we
thought and now without ben
roethlisberger uh everyone's going to
write off the steelers and we'll see
what they can muster as they try to dig
out of their 0-2 hole one of the big
differences in pittsburgh this year
antonio brown obviously gone now with
new england patriots and chris as it
relates to the investigation that the
nfl is conducting into antonio brown
that was sparked by the civil lawsuit
for sexual assault and rape filed last
week we are now in a phase where we're
really not going to hear much
and i saw the reporting yesterday that
antonio brown's accuser was interviewed
for 10 hours on monday that is an
extensive amount of time to talk to
anybody seriously that tells me she had
a lot to say she had a lot of
information the nfl had a lot of
questions and they have drilled this
thing down to every last detail and now
what they will do and again we won't be
privy to any of this they will begin to
follow up they'll try to corroborate or
refute the things she said and at some
point they're going to talk to antonio
brown and antonio brown had better hope
that he's properly prepared and coached
in the right mindset to be a witness to
just answer the questions truthfully
that opposed to you to not try to engage
in swordplay that's the biggest problem
that witnesses get into when they get
irritated by the questions they're being
asked is it they're being faced with
this tough interrogation instead of just
answering the questions meekly they try
to push back they try to fight back and
they find themselves saying outlandish
things as they try to fight the person
who's questioning them that's going to
be the biggest challenge for antonio
brown because based on my understanding
of him chris my read on the guy
when he's under the hot light and when
he's asked a bunch of tough questions i
don't think he's going to be a very good
witness and i think he's going to crack
and he's going to say something that's
going to get him in more trouble than
he's already in yeah well he certainly
hasn't showed us any like you know
cooler heads will prevail or you're
right i mean he seems to have a
temperament and an ego and you're not
allowed to say anything about him i mean
you know
guy what was it two years ago an
si reporter said they were going to
write a story about him and he
threatened to punch him on the jaw and
see how his jaw is on social media so
you're right that would be scary i mean
i guess that was the first moment that
was the first moment where we saw behind
that big smile facade no doubt when we
saw that and it's like whoa what's going
on with ab right and then after that it
was little pieces little pieces little
pieces culminating in where we are but
you know someone told him very early on
in life kids you got a great smile use
it all the time and you'll never have a
problem and behind that smile there is a
raging fire and there's no doubt i mean
gosh i mean you know i felt like you
know we we spent more time on odell
beckham jr's watch than we did with some
of the antonio brown here we go i just
you know are you sure you don't have a
signature tattooed on your arm i don't
but i just it's amazing sometimes i mean
it just i just i'm saying but it is
because of the million dollar
smile like you're said i mean it is he's
just like
if you didn't know him it's the most
lovable smile and like innocent looking
guy ever but we know he ain't that
innocent at this point okay
and he's got big time issues he better
hope
um
that she doesn't have the the text
messages is just all i think about you
know the text messages things like that
where i just look at that as going
that's got to be the most damning
damning information if the nfl has that
available to them through the accuser
then antonio brown could be in some deep
crap and maybe we get a decision quicker
than than we thought if that's the case
and here's what we have to be watching
and waiting for because again there
won't be many leaks now maybe the nfl
will try to pre-position the media and
the fans to what may be coming by
leaking something to the washington post
like they typically do
but he could be put on paid leave like
that right and i wouldn't be surprised
if they do a preliminary interview with
him just to kind of get a feel for what
they're dealing with because remember
the standard for paid leave is the
commissioner believing that the player
may have violated the personal conduct
policy in specific ways that justify
paid leave may have not did may have and
so 10 hours with her if they came out of
that room thinking oh man that's a
compelling story we believe what she's
saying
maybe if they talk to him for a little
bit and he starts to you know flash a
little anger and and not really answer
the questions and and try to evade that
may be enough to get him on paid leave
and meanwhile i wouldn't be surprised to
learn that the patriots are doing their
own shadow investigation
that
will entail them trying to get to the
truth because no matter how long it
takes the nfl to get to the truth the
patriots want to know what's going on
because if this guy's guilty of what
he's accused of they don't want him on
the team so he could be chris it could
be 5 p.m eastern today antonio brown
released by the steeler or by the
patriots and we won't see it coming so
why did that's kind of i the reason i
included this topic today we just need
to be on the lookout for a development
that will be swift and sudden and
potentially severe paid leave by the
league or cut by the patriots and it can
happen at any time yeah right i mean i i
mean i hear you mike i think you're spot
on or i mean what if like
robert klemko finds three or four more
other women who start to say
you know the similar thing that the
woman who is you know apparently
painting a mural of antonio brown if you
get a few more stories like that i think
if just a few more women come out of the
woodworks in general and stuff like that
that that could be even the end of
antonio brown with new england where
they just go okay i mean you know we've
been dealing with smoke and some sparks
of a fire but we got a full-fledged
forest fire here now and we just got to
abandon ship i mean i wouldn't be
shocked if if that happened either
yeah there's a concern as there should
be in any nfl team about the precedent
that is set by cutting a guy based
simply on a civil lawsuit because it is
very easy to make allegations against
someone in a civil setting but once you
start putting meat on the bone that's
when you get concerned so the mere fact
of filing a lawsuit not enough to cut
the guy but
if
evidence begins to mount whether it's
through the nfl's investigation or
whatever the patriots i would guess are
doing very discreetly and quietly right
to test out some of these allegations if
they get to a sense where they're like
yeah this guy's dirty he's gone and you
mentioned otto beckham jr and let me
just let me just end with this because i
agree with you you know um you look at
those two guys
one of those two guys you would feel
comfortable having over at your house
right you would have comfortable right
around people that you care about and
trust that you'd you'd leave them alone
with you know and and i i just based
upon what we've seen and heard publicly
i'm not making any accusations about the
civil lawsuit i don't know anything
about whether those accusations are true
odell beckham jr is a guy i'd want to
hang out with yeah antonio brown based
upon everything we've seen over the last
year is not a guy i would want around me
or anybody that i care about because i
don't know what's going on with that guy
i'm i'm that's fair i think that's spot
on i mean yeah i mean it's like uh yeah
to what you're saying i would trust
odell beckham jr to babysit my kids
antonio brown i would not because i'm
not sure what they would learn or what
he might do or whatever it is so you're
exactly right
and again we are not making factual
accusations this is our opinion based
upon all of the things we have seen yes
there is something going on behind that
smile that isn't happiness right with
otto beckham jr i think fundamentally
he's a good person and he is
misunderstood and part of what he brings
on himself he does
her attention puts him in bad spots
there are unforced errors there but he
is a good person right and with antonio
brown i'm not sufficiently certain that
i would trust him that's all we're
saying yeah that's right we're on
defense yes we're trying to keep us both
out of trouble here yep
right yeah yeah and and and he's earned
every amount of doubt that we would have
about a b because i wouldn't have felt
this way 18 months ago yeah but based on
everything we've seen over the last year
year and a half
i i i don't know what's up with ab right
and i think that's why the patriots are
trying to find out the league's trying
to find out because i don't care how
fast he can run how well he can catch a
football i don't care about any of that
if this is somebody who you just don't
have a good feeling about you don't want
him around your football team and that
may be where this ends up with the new
england patriots
uh that's it uh great job today you too
we'll be back tomorrow with another
edition of pft live when is the next
chris sims unboxing oh today's the
wednesday deep dive so we'll have the
big effer on at some point and i'm gonna
get into some you know film and x's and
o's crap all the stuff you love right
and then and then tomorrow you and i are
gonna have our picks again and we're
going to do that as well chris sims
unbutton p f t p m collaboration i'm not
looking forward to that yeah well and i
i'm keeping track of what went on
because i know i won last week so i'm
going to run i'm not looking forward i'm
not looking forward to that at all uh
last week i took too many chances yeah
uh this week this week it's 16. it's all
chalk baby this week for me i'm going to
get back on my phone took aaron to
rogers you took trevor simeon i took a
baker mayfield give my give my regards
to the big effort and uh we'll look
forward to doing pft live tomorrow and
then our picks for the joint chris sims
unbutton pftpn podcast everybody have a
great day we'll see you on thursday
you